ja ich meine das ist so ein wimmern
giftschrank thema so ein thema extreme
welt wo jedes falsche objektiv konnte
ich sofort die die ewige verbannung
führen lasst uns nicht wirklich
beschäftigt und das ist jetzt sehr stark
geprägt ich meine erfahrung bei mir zu
hause in der schweiz ich komme aus einem
land das ich aufgewachsen bin da musst
du in der schweiz seine wohnung nicht
abschließt da war quasi die reine idylle
und das land lasse sich und was mir
auffällt in letzter zeit ist der ganz
alltägliche gewalt waren sich begegnen
einfach eine meldung zum beispiel
kürzlich stadt zürich neun von zehn
jungen frauen die am abend
sich da draußen etwas bewegen fühlen
sich bedrängt sexuell belästigt neun von
zehn wenn man ein bisschen nach die
täter die belästiger
migrationshintergrund am letzten samstag
in einer tankstelle im kanton luzern das
ist der solide innerschweiz
20 männer aus syrien nord mazedonien
und irak gehen mit messern hämmern und
steinen aufeinander los gibt einen toten
heute lese ich in der zeitung mark rutte
der niederländische ministerpräsident
das sind zustände wie mexiko sieht jetzt
wird er offenbar von einem drogenkartell
der rat folgt dass der personenschutz
haben muss weil sie angst haben dass der
umgebracht wird um mein eindruck ist
einfach dass dieses ganze thema der
migration und der damit verbundenen
migrations getriebenen gewalt überhaupt
kein thema ist in der öffentlichkeit in
der politik die politiker leben reden
lieber vom klima dieses unangenehme im
braune thema das möchte man gar nicht
ansprechen und da plädiere ich einfach
dafür das ist der falsche weg mit dem
radikalisiert man die leute man muss da
einen sachlichen wirklichkeit bezogenen
ansatz entwickeln und darüber offen
sprechen auch streiten es kann
vielleicht auch falsche thesen geben
aber dieses thema migrations getriebene
alltägliche gewalt diese wahnsinn der
sich da ausbreitet das scheint mir
einfach ein völlig unterschätzt ist ich
bin grundsätzlich auch wirklich ich bin
nah bei dir was ich halt ganz wichtig
finde da immer dazu zu sagen das ist
alles ist essenziell dass es noch
wichtiger als das was du jetzt
richtigerweise vielleicht ausgeführt hat
aber wir können das ist schon mal der
erste fehler wir können nicht so
anfangen zu sagen das ist die migration
das sind die flüchtlinge das
funktioniert nämlich nicht ich weiß
nicht wie es in der schweiz ist ich bin
jetzt die zahlen aus deutschland die
deutschen kriminalitätsstatistiken
dass wir da nicht alle über einen kamm
scheren und sagen es sind jetzt die
syrer die iraker wenn wir uns zahlen
daten fakten anschauen da bin ich mal
ein riesengroßer fan von da sehen wir
gewalt ist männlich und sie ist jung und
es ist nicht alle im migrationsgruppen
gleichermaßen betroffen sonst sind in
erster linie auch nordafrikaner und das
sind das ist natürlich etwas unbequem
aber ich muss alle allerwichtigste
diskussion ist das auch zu
differenzieren weil wir das nicht tun
und wenn wir dieses holding benutzen da
fangen die probleme schon anwender trotz
kann er an das war ja auch ein fachlich
nicht richtig also geht es in völliger
einfach da natürlich das ist ja klar ich
meine du hast ja sehr viele leute das
unterschiedlichen ländern die sich
problemlos integrieren das interne
pauschale urteile aber das interessante
ist eben das
im bestreben eigentlich zu
differenzieren wird das thema oft
gänzlich tabu sind kommt es gar nicht
aufs tapet du kannst dann gar nichts
sagen zum beispiel in der schweiz hatten
wir regelungen in einzelnen städten
dadurch sogar nicht schreibe die polizei
durfte nicht melden wenn der täter einen
migrationshintergrund und ich habe noch
ein zweites thema ein zweites thema in
diesem zusammenhang was mich wirklich
beendet mainz in der schweiz für iraker
wenn diese begriffe von weiß man das
sind leute die sind 2015 größter
wahrscheinlichkeit über die asyl schiene
ins land gekommen und da frage ich mich
jetzt ohne das im detail quasi durch
statistisch analysiert haben was läuft
in unserem asylwesen schief weil das
können ja keine flüchtlinge seien die
dankbar sind dass sie hier sind wenn sie
mit steinen und messen und hämmern auf
andere ausländer losgehen diese leute
und das ist mein zweiter punkt hier ich
glaube im asylwesen läuft etwas
grundsätzlich schief ich bin ein
verfechter des asylsystems ich sage asyl
das ist eine ganz noble tradition aber
asyl heißt x16 deutsches grundgesetz in
der schweiz genauer bereich asyl für
menschen die aufgrund ohne ein trinker
persönliche eigenschaften an leib und
leben bedroht sind die bekommen ausüben
da gibt's die kriegs vertriebenen aber
der große teil sind wirtschaftsmigranten
für die ich verständnis habe aber die
dürfen wir nicht unter dem titel asyl
reinnehmen und da sind die politiker für
mich kommen sie zu leicht weg weil sie
haben es zugelassen dass dieses asyl
haus entstanden ist und das sind die
folgen und man will nicht darüber reden
ich bin auch er bei frau wusste was muss
ich sagen ich finde das zu
pauschalisierend über die migranten in
verbindung mit gewalt zu sprechen
natürlich gibt es diese fälle geht so
nicht mehr auch natürlich das sind schon
ich sage die täter kommen von diesen
seien und immer jahre aussagen über
diese aussage man darf nicht darüber
sprechen also ich glaube talkshow
deutschland auch wir und andere sprechen
ist eigentlich sehr häufig ist das
problematisch das ist zumindest der ich
annehme also erst will das vielleicht
seid ihr schon immer wieder zum thema
maria es probleme gibt dafür angefeindet
werden auch oft genug muss man ja auch
sagen also heutzutage ich habe die fälle
genau nationalität von tätern zu
benennen da gibt es fälle in deutschland
wo dafür verantwortliche beamte bei der
polizei angeprangert werden
innenminister angeprangert werden weil
man es dann als rassismus bezeichnet
oder aus falsch verstandener toleranz
die dinge nicht beim namen nennt und da
muss ich auch sagen da haben die leute
ein ziemlich feines gefühl dafür
aufführt auch zurück zum thema osten in
der frage wie beschreibt man eigentlich
die lebensrealitäten und ich glaube das
thema ist viel zu wichtig um es nur der
afg zu überlassen das ist das große
problem weil die afg behandelt diese
themen mit so einer haltung wir wollen
grundsätzlich keine zuwanderung
zuwanderer sind alle schlecht die sind
nur schlecht für sozialsystem die sind
kriminell das ist ein völlig falsches
bild man muss licht und schatten dabei
benennen und ich glaube da ist das große
große problem dass wir da oft in der tat
manchmal dann die auseinandersetzung
auch mit dem grünen licht suchen wenn
man in der frage analyse vom wahlkampf
das können sie dann jetzt ja in den
koalitionsverhandlungen jahren das wird
den grünen bestimmt gut gefahren ja ich
glaube jedenfalls man muss klar benennen
dass wir die migrationspolitischen
punkte der grünen nicht einfach
übernehmen können weil die wollen an
vielen stellen der ungesteuerte
zuwanderung und vor allem eine
ausweitung der zuwanderung über das
asylsystem am ende und da wir haben es
fachkräfte einwanderungsgesetz wieder
markant ausgang wirklich haben will dann
zusammen wenn sie jamal körper und dann
kann zusammenkommen es gibt
überschneidung punkte auch in der
innenpolitik aber ich finde das wichtige
ist man muss dann auch klar benennen was
die unterschiede sind bei der frage grad
mit den grünen zusammen zu arbeiten ich
hab gesagt gerade im osten gibt es da
viel kritik für skepsis des vorbild ist
sebastian kurz und die österreicher wie
dies machen indem man nämlich klar
benennt wer welche punkte wie adressiert
und da würde ich sagen bei der frage
integration haben die grünen ja
vielleicht vernünftige aspekte bei der
frage begrenzung und steuerung der
zuwanderung will ich lieber in cdu hand
lassen es ist laut es ist ein kurz
gesagt hat ich nehme niemanden auf das
hab ich für ausgeschlossen
das halte ich für zu pauschalisiert
gehalten aber auch da liegt die wahrheit
in der mitte man muss eher sind die
grünen waren natürlich aus meiner sicht
dabei mancher stelle auch zu vorschnell
wir können nicht sagen
sie werden kanzler kurz wünschen in
deutschland ist haben viele damals
gesagt werden auch gerne jemanden ich
finde ihn sebastian kurz super aber
werden auch guten kanzlerkandidaten
gehabt so
kanzler ist ja auch immer noch aber dass
er bis zum wahltag und jetzt wird er
hoffentlich noch bundeskanzler wenn es
gut läuft so am ende sagt ich habe das
entscheidende ist zum beispiel auch beim
thema afghanistan so eine haltung zu
sagen wir beteiligen uns gar nicht
kannst als kleineres land vielleicht
machen ich fand richtig dass wir es mit
den orts kräften dann diese lösung
gefunden aber so eine pauschale haltung
zu sagen wir lösen alle probleme der
welt in den deutschen staatsgrenzen der
rassen
diese grüne halt wird aber nicht genau
wir lösen alles in den grenzen
deutschlands wir sind dann moralisch
super zufrieden haben können haken dran
machen
was ich einbringen kann das haben wir
noch nicht gesagt dass du dich eben auch
interessant ich bin vor ruhig ich habe
selber migrationshintergrund und meine
familie sind derzeit im ausland studiert
aber entscheidende punkt ist doch es
schwingt da immer so ein paar vorwurf
auch an zum beispiel die deutschen mit
da kommt diese ausländerfeindlichkeit
aber ich sage euch jetzt das ist mein
bild von deutschland deutschland ist
doch ein unglaublich welt wo sie
einbrechen um einen deutschen einen lohn
unterhalb der durch
[Musik]